christmas christmas time is here time
for toys and time for cheer
now if you're like me you might have
some libs in your family and even among
your friends
and you still probably want to buy them
a christmas present but what do you get
for that wonderful lib in your life
trust me i'm like a smart person well i
have the definitive
ranking here of all of the woke
christmas presents before we get started
this video is sponsored by established
titles established titles is a wonderful
way to become a lord or lady such as i
lord michael knowles today more from
them later first
we've got four tiers here okay
for the most basic gifts for your lib
friends that that would be
for the friends who they just watch cnn
cnn should be ashamed of itself right
they just they get all their news from
cnn so okay that's the c
tier then there's the b tier this is for
your friends and family who maybe wore a
mask at thanksgiving
not great then you get to the a tier
these are the people who have one of
those lawn signs you know the lawn sign
it says i believe
and it's not it's like i believe in dr
fauci and i believe that people should
do whatever weird sex stuff they want
it's like that
really weird lib sign so that that's
like for those people
and then there's the s tier
this is the furthest down the road this
is the absolute
highest level of lib
this is for the sort of person who
attends
a wnba championship parade
and there are gifts for these people
without further ado let's take a look at
the presents
they them
non-binary pronoun coffee mug okay
i guess you could you could get this for
someone ironically so like i would like
that that would be kind of funny
although really my pronouns now are just
lord and lord because i'm a scottish
lord we'll get more on that later but if
you're going to get this earnestly it's
not just that you watch cnn there are
plenty of people who watch cnn who are
not down for like transiting all the
kids
yeah you know you definitely have an i
believe lawn sign but do you go to the
so few people go to the wnba
championship parade i'm gonna say this
would be a tier you have an i believe
long sign
uh this man ate my son vinyl sticker of
ted cruz oh my gosh
that's not nice it's not nice to make
jokes about people
who are serial killers it's not smart
either because they
they can come get you you thought that
you had zodiac under under arrest in
california not quite this is like really
basic level it's like oh i hate ted cruz
because he's conservative wow what
that's
sea tier that's just your regular cnn
jesus was a brown-skinned refugee oh my
gosh here we go first of all if you say
jesus was
probably you don't take jesus very
seriously i'm ultra spiritual sort of
the central fact
in the life of jesus
is that jesus is he
died on the cross he is resurrected
before
satan fall before i saw satan fall like
lightning before abraham was i am right
i am that i am so
just a minor
major theological point there
so
you have to have a an ignorance of in
contempt for christianity
so definitely you
you only watch cnn cnn frankly might be
too conservative for you do you wear the
mask at thanksgiving
yeah yeah for sure you do do you have
the i believe son yeah because the you
know don't forget the i believe sign is
just another kind of creed
right the creed the credo in
christianity means i believe
right i believe in god the father
almighty creator of heaven and earth and
what the libs have is this new thing
they say i believe in science and dr
fauci almighty and right and they just
it's a parallel heretical religion so
but do you attend the championship and
wnba parade no you don't this is eight
year
i love it when i wake up
and trump is not president
oh yeah okay come on this is weak sauce
libs
that's not that's so lame it's lame
that's cnn it's just like oh i hate
trump bad oh okay wow really interesting
you've made me think about donald trump
in this new and insightful way wow thank
you okay
see you we need to talk about the
elephant in the womb
oh get it
yeah the elephant because the gop wants
to go inside your womb
and pull out the doctor's knife and hand
trying to kill a baby yeah that's always
bad geo peers not letting some other guy
stick his hand in my womb and kill a
baby wow they're so but this is pretty
lame
again this is not
very advanced stuff this is very shallow
long time you know boomer kind of tier
uh slogan earring about political issues
so that's that's going to be c
saint bernie prayer candle oh man
oh my gosh they did a lot of these for
fouchy or uh rbg they actually did ruth
bader ginsburg until they had to had to
start editing the interviews with ruth
ginsberg because she was too
conservative for them that's what katie
couric did
saint bernie uh
now bernie he's not a total corporate
democrat in the way that the clintons
are for instance so
guess you probably wore a mask at
thanksgiving but some of the people who
like bernie are kind of crunchy people
you know like joe rogan liked bernie
right joe rogan's kind of right wing now
he's kind of he's definitely not
a far leftist the joe biden guy guy can
barely remember what he's talking about
while he's talking or is it the i
believe because it's a pick on a
parallel religion right it's instead of
a saint it's bernie sanders i'm gonna um
i'm gonna say this is
war mask at thanksgiving this is b level
oh okay here we go now we're really
upping the ante this is an icon
of aoc
as some kind of
saint
and aoc is kind of mainstream now as
well
aoc is a little edgier than bernie
sanders you probably have a lawn sign
that's going to be a tier
if you have that lady on your shirt
if you are a lady or you are a lord or
you identify as a lady or a lord then
you need to get the title to reflect
your true identity deep down which is
why i would strongly recommend you check
out established titles
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of lord or lady in
scotland just like me
your humble host lord michael knowles
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land and a certificate established
titles is a project based on an historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards
or lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you will receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land you could even get
a couple pack for you and your spouse or
loved one of unspecified
distinction you will be able to have
land right next to one another at one
square foot and you will both get to be
called lord and lady you can get this on
your credit card on your plane tickets
you can even put it on your dating
profiles
established titles currently having a
massive holiday sale on top of that sale
you can get an additional 10 off any
purchase you make with discount code
knowles so click the link below or go to
establishtitles.com knowles use promo
codenoles to save an extra 10
today all right let's keep going with
the producer picked gifts bernie sanders
wall art again this is kind of basic
tier
you know bernie sanders
pretending to be some civil rights icon
this is you just wore a mask at
thanksgiving that's b-tier
cats not capitalism coffee mug yeah
cat's not capitalism buy my cheap
chinese good on etsy or whatever and
give me your money for this schlock
because i hate capitalism
okay we've got to have
money
do you know what capitalism is are you
the least self-aware person
in the world
very
basic stuff i mean i guess not all cnn
viewers hate capitalism
you know i mean frankly capitalism works
pretty well for the woke they hijack all
of these companies and so in many ways
the great anti-capitalist resistance
these days is being led on the right
because the capitalist fat cats like
bill gates and bezos and all the rest of
them are destroying our country
zuckerberg and
jack dorsey
if you're getting into the isms okay
this is a tier you you probably have the
sign in your yard
may your days be bright and your
feminism intersectional
i'm gonna say
well feminism is so mainstream this is
really sad
because the left has moved the overton
window so far to the left that now
intersectional feminism is kind of the
baseline
i think this is this is c tier
okay
there we go there's the rbg descent i
dis this is extremely basic dear
this i even know this is how
how effective the propaganda is i know
people who are sort of conservative or
who would consider themselves moderate
to slightly conservative
who love rbg because she has been made
into an icon and a secular saint can't
get rid of me
and so even
some sort of less informed
people in the middle and on the right
kind of like her this is sea tier this
is just the cnn level
eat the rich okay now we're getting a
little more into it eat the rich
earrings
so you you have a and i believe lawn
sign but do you um
is this the you know
no in order to reach the s tier
i don't think it's enough to just engage
in old-school class warfare like they
did 150 years ago i think you need a
little more race or sex or something to
kind of spice it up but this is a tier
you have the lawn sign
pay me like a white man okay now we're
getting into it pay me like a white man
hmm
actually think about it think about
someone you know who would wear that
shirt would it be the most ardent
radical revolutionary antifa member or
would it be just some like silly
millennial girl
frankly probably a white girl here's
the [ __ ]
t
i think probably it would be the latter
i think that it is now completely
mainstream
to scapegoat white men for every problem
in the world and say that you know all
all non-white people are good all white
people are bad all non
men
i guess women i know there are a lot of
genders now but i guess that's women all
women good all men bad and and so this
is not only tolerated but this is
actually encouraged and there's actually
legal discrimination against white guys
through affirmative action so
sorry to say this is c tier this is
basic level cnn stuff
okay
all right so the progressive pride flag
hoodie
this would be
a debate this it's not not just cnn it's
not just the war the mask of
thanksgiving if it were just the rainbow
flag i would say it's only a tier but
there's this new rainbow flag you know
it's not just the rainbow which is for
all the sex stuff it's the pride
progress flag which includes some
transgender stuff and black people i
don't know when black people became a
sex but black people are a sex now
according to these guys sexual chocolate
and so this is pretty new you got to be
pretty plugged in
you've got to be pretty gender bending
obviously to put the transgender stuff
in there so i think you might be the one
and only person
who attends the wnba championship
parade this is the official uniform of
the wnba championship parade
tax the rich aoc met gala ornament oh my
god also that's not what aoc looks like
that looks like an inca woman i that
looks a little
is it
is that racist i don't know i don't know
who knows what racist is anymore but i
i don't it's certainly not good art
look we're talking about the met gala
we're talking about the boogiest
most
elite
capitalist event in new york and then
they've got their court jester socialist
aoc shows up and she does a little soft
shoe and then they say oh good job good
job you all right now go go you know and
then aoc gets to hobnob with all the
rich people so this is kind of basic
stuff you wore a mask at thanksgiving
you know you probably have this as a
novelty that's b-tier
safe space
wall hanging banner okay you have a long
sign this is this this could be the lawn
sign frankly i bet one of the variations
of this hanging banner is just the lawn
sign like a silly phone
all right here's the last one they tell
me
it's a beautiful day to smash the
patriarchy
this
this is the lowest tier possible this is
you just watch cnn i know that sounds
crazy because it's so radical and you
talk about the patriarchy or what this
is completely mainstream you could buy
that pillow i bet at t.j.maxx tj maxx
it's like if goodwill is in a gated
community okay this is kitsch it's like
cutesy now it's like
we're gonna we're gonna smash the
patriarchy if thomas kincaid had lived
you would see these things in thomas
kincaid paintings
that is how
sentimental and cutesy they have become
and that's very sad they should be
considered radical but
but they are not so was there only there
was only one ester there it was just the
pride progress
hoodie only one person gets to watch the
wnba championship parade which checks
out
with reality if you just look at the
video there is only one person who does
that happy shopping
mallord and m'ladies out there happy
shopping i hope that the libs in your
lives
are delighted and that you can calibrate
your christmas gifts to their level of
wokeness see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you